your fame is still fairly recent and you
went from you know struggling and and
and and trying to get parts - everybody
knows you and you're very popular what
about when you're family that's not used
to being in the show business world is
with you and I see someone famous do
they act cool they've been great around
like the cast and that's frickin Ted
Danson yeah I mean and they we there was
a few years ago I remember we I was
about to do a movie with Molly Shannon
the great Molly Shannon again like a an
amazing hilarious woman that I grew up
being in love with and we we were the
timing of this was insane we were about
to do this movie together we had never
met before and I was at a deli with my
parents and we had just been talking
about her that day it was too much it
was weird and as we're standing in line
of the deli in walks Molly Shannon right
and she gets in line behind us and I was
like oh wait can I say what are we yeah
no you can't right and II said during
the show I said music or did I say and
you say under eyes that can use it okay
yeah yeah okay we're now we're at the
yeah
Somali walked in and I was like hope and
that's too much I can't use the boat
there's a way this is done and you you
just burned up our quota for the and so
to be cool I texted my parents Molly
Shannon is behind us right now and then
my dad looks at his phone and he just
goes Molly Shannon good shoes right
there that's fantastic